hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to be talking about motos and roio
so myoto is a technique uh it's known by
a lot of different names in fact the
style I learned it in we called it KAG
um but there are so many things called
KAG that when I started teaching I
needed a different name for it so I
pulled my otoshi from another style of
iido to use the term motoshi um it's a
really good technique that I think kind
of gets a bad rep because it looks kind
of weird um and in fact I believe it is
just another variation on aoko so we're
also going to talk about rokio in this
and I think rokio is the big category
and motos is kind of a subcategory that
but I'm gonna get Josh over here we're
going to talk about it
Josh all right so today we're going to
talk about motos and uh roio and Josh's
sport in the top knot today uh in true
samurai fashion all right so uh what is
my so we call myoto this thing right so
I'm sure your school has some name for
this that this equivalent kind of
technique um in this uh the way it's
kind of classically shown is the
teachers will roll someone up onto the
tip of the toes and then project them
forward into the mat right and that's
kind of the the the root idea or the the
thing you most commonly see in different
styles um when I learned that I thought
it was really kind of dumb because I was
like well who the heck's going to stand
there while you lift the them off the
ground like this and then project them
forward and and I don't know it just
didn't didn't make too much sense to me
but um as I started to work with more
live practice I noticed myself basically
doing that technique and something that
looked a little simpler than that but
but basically doing that technique and
it would happen a lot if I was caught
like this and I needed to turn quick and
pop someone's arm off right and that's
how I did it and saw it a lot and so
once I started doing that I was like oh
yeah this is a pretty legit technique
you know but it took me a while to kind
of figure out what all the little
details are right so one part of that I
believe this part is actually an attempt
to clear and no he's not going to stand
there generally while I do this what
he's going to do is hate that and he's
going to come off on my wrist which is
what I want right and so this is just a
way to really extend into it right so as
I'm twisting kind of lining up my arm a
little bit and really going into the
back of that elbow and I'm using that
elbow to raise him up right now a lot of
times when you see it in schools you'll
see people kind of doing it like this
and this is a really impossible way to
get this to come off and you know maybe
I'm missing some subtlety but I I did
originally learn it this way also um but
this is a real difficult way to get
anything to happen because he's really
stable right here he has no reason to
want to to move at all and so I could
probably wrestle with them a lot like
this and it's not until I add the
emphasis to the Elbow here now I could
be here and put this on my body and use
my body to do that it's just not quite
as tight if I slide my arm over a little
more I get a little bit more out of it
right and as far as the throwing goes
this is how I feel about anything sure
someone might be thrown by that and it
is called otoshi and OSI means to drop
something down so it could be that I did
it really hard and they smashed their
face on the ground but in my opinion
it's more a hoki right so the idea is
more like hoki and kind of the way I
teach everything is really hoki at its
core and then if they stayed on they
would get thrown or dropped or whatever
right but that's the basic idea seeing
it from gak is a really nice way to see
it comes off really really clean um but
it could come off lots of ways it could
have come off if he had something in his
hand too and I was holding and trying to
pop his hand off of it as well right so
that's my basic idea with that I think
this technique is a roo technique and so
when I talk about technique uh the
technique of rokio I'm talking about the
principle of locking the elbow out so to
me anything that does this hyperextends
this elbow joint is a roio so anything
that does that's a roio so that means
this which is the classic Roo I'm doing
that against my body here so I'm pulling
my body in and driving it like that
that's a roo if you see any kind of
variation of a throw like this where
it's on my shoulder here and I'm
cranking down on this that's a rokio so
anytime I lock this arm out so I think
You' just call it an armar bar in modern
lingo right so anything like that would
be a roo so we're hyperextending the
elbow it's a really important principle
because when I talk about the arm I like
to say that the arm really has three
main configurations that's hand up hand
down and straight arm right so stuff for
in iido that's for this is like um the
kotay Kish is for this stuff for things
like this or eeko Sono right so there's
lots of stuff for that for this rokio is
our main go-to right and that's
basically what's going to happen as I as
I work this guy some way where so like
if I'm really trying to turn a kod hard
and he wants to resist that he'll lock
that arm out that immediately gives me
this roko boom that I can turn into
right here so anytime I turn into that
uh elbow right there we're getting a roo
and so that's the principal roko and my
to is just a variation on this principle
of rokio so understanding straight arms
Super Key you got to be able to do it um
there are times when other ier
techniques will make good sense off of a
straight arm right so like one of my
favorite things to show is a shag and I
think in the Shag talk that I did just a
little bit ago like two weeks ago I
talked about this but if I'm really
cranking here and he tries to pull his
arm back this quickly leads to a really
nice shag really nice shag comes out of
that and that's because I'm trying to
crank his arm there and you might say
you know why would you crank on his arm
like that in iido um if I was trying to
strip something out of his hand so if he
had something here and pulling against
it like this and I should have grabbed
something when I came over here but well
hang on movie Magic so if you had
something like this and I cranked on it
like this and ground it back right you
can see how I might need the strip like
that now if as I'm trying to do that he
pulls his arm up and I turn I can come
in here and get all kinds of sweet stuff
right from that so basically um uh that
straight arm bar is going to be
essential anytime you're doing grappling
over the arm um why would we do that in
iido well because he's holding me and so
I need to clear my hand or because he
had something in his hand and I've got
to take it out um that's why we would
see it in Nido and that's all of course
a hold over from classical Jiu-Jitsu and
understand that Jiu-Jitsu and iido are
related in technical syllabus but the
principle of why you would use those
things is different so an iido it's kind
of anti- Jiu-Jitsu I'm trying to get
free and and be autonomous and then as
I'm autonomous I can make ACC chords
which is what I want to do and in
Jiu-Jitsu the purpose is to dominate
them to get on top of them and and beat
them and make them do what you want
right so that's basically the difference
between the two Styles but as far as
Tech teal syllabus goes they're very
very similar because there's so much uh
intersectionality between the two so I
hope that helped a little bit with myot
Tosh and roio um I'm Chris fry it's
Joshua T my Salo Daniels behind that
Center camera right there doing some
wiggle fingers we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
a